>>> PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY IS NOW
WARNING THAT RUSSIAN FORCES NOW
CONTROL SOME 20% OF HIS COUNTRY
AS THE KREMLIN MAKES A MAJOR
PUSH TO CLAIM THE DONBAS REGION.
CNN'S MELISSA BELL IS STANDING
BY LIVE FOR US IN ODESA, UKRAINE
FOR US.
SHE'S GOT DETAILS.
I UNDERSTAND FIERCE FIGHTING
CONTINUES IN THE EAST WHERE
RUSSIA IS ATTEMPTING TO ENCIRCLE
UKRAINIAN DEFENDERS.
WHO'S THE LATEST?
>> Reporter: REALLY THAT PART OF
THE COUNTRY, WOLF, WHERE IT HAD
CONCENTRATED MANPOWER, FIRE
POWER, STILL SENDING MORE
EQUIPMENT UP THAT WAY.
NOT JUST TO DONETSK, BUT OTHER
CITIES WE'RE TOLD BY UKRAINE AND
CITIES UNDER SEVERE ATTACK
INCLUDING THAT IMPORTANT CITY
FOR UKRAINIAN SUPPLY LINES.
ELSEWHERE, MOUNTING AN OFFENSIVE
IF KHERSON.
20% OF THE COUNTRY, WOLF, THAT
PART OF UKRAINE BEYOND OUR
REACH.
WE WERE HEARING FROM PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY TODAY SAYING SOME
200,000 CHILDREN HE SAYS HAVE
BEEN TAKEN FROM RUSSIA, TO
RUSSIA RATHER FROM UKRAINE.
DIFFICULT FOR US TO SAY.
WE HAVE NO ACCESS TO THAT PART
OF THE COUNTRY.
YOU HAVE THE MILITARY LINE THAT
STRETCHES FOR 1,000 KILOMETERS.
FROM MYKOLAIV UP TO KHARKIV THEN
YOU HAVE A COMMUNICATIONS LINE,
A POLITICAL LINE, AND A LINE TO
WHICH WE SIMPLY, THROUGH WHICH
WE CAN'T GET THROUGH AN
INCREASING NUMBER OF CITIZENS
ARE NOW BEING STUCK.
FOR THE TIME BEING, 20% IN
RUSSIAN HANDS AND PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY CLEARLY TO BREAK THAT
LINE THROUGH KHERSON.
>> MELISSA BELL FROM ODESA IN
UKRAINE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
STAY
>>> LET'S DIG DEEPER NOW WITH
RETIRED U.S. AIR FORCE COLONEL
CEDRIC LEIGHTON, THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR JOINING US.
WHERE EXACTLY ARE THESE LINES OF
CONTROL AS THEY'RE CALLED,  RUS
WHAT, ABOUT A FIFTH OF THE
COUNTRY?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, ABOUT THE SIZE
OF MISSISSIPPI IS THE TERRITORY
THE RUSSIANS CONTROL IN UKRAINE,
SO IF WE LOOK AT THE MAP HERE,
WHAT WE ARE SEEING IS AN AREA
THROUGH KHARKIV, THIS WAY DOWN
TOWARDS KHERSON.
THIS IS AN AREA OF CONTROL THE
RUSSIANS HAVE AND IN ESSENCE ARE
FIGHTING THE UKRAINIANS IN THIS
AREA BECAUSE WHAT THEY NEED TO
DO IS BE ABLE TO CONTROL THIS
AREA, IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE ONE OF
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S MAIN WAR AIMS
WHICH IS TO CONTROL THE DONBAS
REGION.
>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THIS KEY
CITY, SEVERODONETSK, WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW IN WHAT'S
GOING ON THERE.
>> SO THIS IS CRITICAL, WOLF,
BECAUSE SEVERODONETSK IS REALLY
THE KEY POINT, IT'S RIGHT HERE,
RIGHT IN THIS PART OF THE
LUHANSK, REGION, THE LUHANSK
REGION IS THE NORTHERN PART OF
THE DONBAS AREA.
THE ONLY PART THE UKRAINIANS
CONTROL OF THIS AREA IS THIS
PART RIGHT HERE THAT IS RIGHT
AROUND SEVERODONETSK AND JUST
NORTH OF THE TOWN OF POPOSNA.
WHAT THIS MEANS IS IN
SEVERODONETSK, THIS CRITICAL
JUNCTION IS ONE OF THE AREAS
WHERE THE UKRAINIANS ARE GOING
TO NEED TO NEED TO KEEP THIS, IF
THEY WANT TO KEEP THIS
CONTROLLED, BUT THE OTHER
PROBLEM THEY HAVE IS IT'S VERY
EASY FOR THE RUSSIANS TO CUT
THEM OFF AT THIS PARTICULAR
POINT.
IF THE RUSSIANS DO THAT, THE
UKRAINIAN FORCES RISK BEING
SURROUNDED AND THAT IS GOING TO
BE A HUGE PROBLEM FOR THEM.
>> SO WHAT DO YOU THINK THE RISK
IS OF THESE UKRAINIAN TROOPS
BEING ENCIRCLED THERE?
>> IT'S VERY HIGH, WOLF, AND THE
UKRAINIANS HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL TO CONSERVE THEIR
FORCES.
IF THEY DON'T CONSERVE THEIR
FORCES WILL LOSE A LARGE PORTION
OF THEIR MILITARY AND WOULD BE
DISASTROUS FOR THEIR WAR EFFORT.
>> SO YOU THINK THERE'S AN AREA
THE UKRAINIANS COULD WITHDRAW.
>> YES, IF THEY USE THIS AREA
HERE, THEY STILL HAVE AN OPEN
PATH BACK INTO THE
UKRAINIAN-CONTROLLED AREAS.
IF THEY DO THAT, THEN THEY WILL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO SAVE THAT
PORTION OF THEIR ARMY.
THAT'S GOING TO BE CRITICAL.
IF THEY DON'T DO THAT, THEY RISK
LOSING THAT ARMY A